Let's check out where and
how to configure build types.
Since build types are only relevant to
the android component of this build,
we need to check out the build.gradle
file in the app folder.
Build types are declared in
the build types script log.
Here we can see that android studio
has already added some additional
configuration to the release
build type for us.
Take note, although debug isn't listed
here, the debug build type still exists.
In this case,
we are disabling packaging optimizations
by setting minifyEnabled to false.
Also, we are configuring where
the android plug in should look for
proguard configuration.
We'll talk more about
proguard in lesson four.
If we open up the gradle pane to
look at the available tasks for
our project we see that we have assemble
tasks for each one of our build types.
So we have assemble debug and
assemble release.
Another way to pick which build type we
want to build is by opening up the build
variance pane.
And then we can select between debug and
release.
Let's say we were building a game and
wanted to make a build for a QA testing
that's exactly like the release build
except it bundles in sheets for
infinite gold or
to skip levels or whatever.
We can easily declare a new build
type by adding it to the build types
block like cell.